and we will continue at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 with our caller from the 702 area
code caller from 702 please tell us who
you are and what's on your mind today
alright what can we do for you ok please
speak up as much as you can because I
can barely hear you ok ok yeah just talk
as loud as you can
alright I'm fairly new here so forgive
you've been asked so if this is where
the discourses you you think you'll
focus your channel more on stuff like
that or whenever there's anything that
pertains there for the topic so we kind
of date the course you know I heard
you're really you've got a bad
connection I heard sjw's an alt right
just restate just the question part
you're asking me if I'll focus more on
what instead of what else we focus more
on like the all right time you know or
on that we're talking about the all
right Pat can you interpret the question
for me he means will you talk about the
Albright social justice warriors a
little bit more because those seems to
be a little bit more topical now versus
issues like we normally discuss
economics gay marriage abortion all that
stuff I mean we did a long-form
investigation into the alt-right we did
one on so-called regressive left ISM
which really is authoritarian leftism
yeah I mean I've criticized safe spaces
and and that type of thing so yeah I
mean as necessary we'll we'll talk about
it you know what
I think that that will do it will do the
topics justice or something like that
yeah okay all right better connection
next time okay because that was that was
tough that was a real tough one